hello everyone in this video I'm going
to address two of the biggest mistakes
which students do in high school well by
high school I do not actually mean the
levels of 11th standard and 12th
standard rather I mean the levels from
around class 6 standard 6 or standard 7
to standard 10 so uh what are these two
biggest mistakes first of all the uh the
the absolute biggest mistake my personal
feeling is how the students uh in their
high school they study and learn
mathematics and how they engage in
problem solving the second one is how
they go about acquiring language skills
irrespective of the language in question
so first of all mathematics and problem
solving so uh recently I had uh I shared
a poll uh on YouTube uh through the
YouTube Community uh thing and uh people
had many students had correctly pointed
out that if they had a chance to go back
to school they would emphasize mostly
this aspect mathematics and problem
solving and I completely agree with that
uh the the main reason behind this is as
follows you see many many students in
fact most students in India they have
this dream of going to a good
engineering College possibly the iits uh
if not uh the nits so the target is
always J in some cases it is not J it is
neat but more or less the mentality is
the same so uh when they go about doing
this uh they mostly take the help of
coaching institutes and uh I was kind of
shocked to learn that nowadays people
are going to coaching institutes as
early as standard 6 or standard 7 okay I
had heard that people go as early as
standard 9th uh which was a little bit
odd during our T because coaching really
started in standard 11th
but I could understand standard 9th but
standard 6 come on are you kidding me
anyway so my hope is that if you can if
you can address the kind of things that
I'm going to discuss right now uh you
would not even need the help of coaching
institutes if done right so what is this
problem what is what is the biggest
mistake that people do in um learning
maths and uh how they engage in problem
solving so you say how do you go about
learning maths in school is it not
something as follows you get your
textbook you uh go to school the teacher
starts a particular chapter explains a
few uh things from the background Theory
and then uh he or she uh your teacher uh
they they they teach a few sample
problems and then maybe they will give
you a few homework problems to do and
then uh what you usually do this is my
experience from my days and I think this
is more or less true for for many
students also nowadays that even if they
don't go to coaching they will
definitely take some kind of tution in
maths this is the most common thing like
tution in maths is a necessity an
absolute necessity in school um so
people who not take tution they feel
that they are left out so uh uh and and
the system goes like this that the kind
of homework uh problems that the teacher
gives in school that is being uh
discussed in the tution and then the
tution teacher maybe gives another set
of homeworks which the students try and
then they go back and then they discuss
these problems so basically what it
turns out is that uh learning maths as
it turns out happens to be a process
through which the students learn various
kinds of solution methodologies from
different persons whether it is the
school teacher whether it is the tuition
teacher this is what goes on in the name
of learning
maths but where is the learning of
problem solving who is teaching problem
solving to the students I am afraid this
is not happening at all okay there may
be some very very good schools or very
very good teachers and these are
exceptions who emphasize on the
importance of problem solving but mostly
what happens in the name of problem
solving quote unquote is that to the
students are just being taught different
kinds of solution methodologies that's
that so and why is that bad well if if
you're only learning different kinds of
solution strategies and
methodologies like it's like um you are
just mugging up the methods to uh to
address different kinds of problems so
there will be some set categories of
problems for which you will have a
catalog of methods and then your
training is geared towards how you can
map the different kinds of methodologies
the different kinds of methods to the
various categories of problems it is
basically ultimately at a slightly
higher level uh just match the
following so this is not really problem
solving at all what is problem solving
well you you see a problem you have no
idea about what the method what method
you have to um you have to come up with
and then you use your own independent
thinking without discussion with anyone
without looking up any problem without
searching for it in Google and then
through your independent effort you try
to tackle even if partially the problem
that is real problem solving like you
may acquire a long I mean a large amount
of problem solving even without doing
completely a single
problem but through an honest effort
towards tackling different kinds of
problems unless you do this you are not
learning problem solving and math and
and and if you do not learn problem
solving in the context of mathematics
you are never going to learn problem
solving I'm I'm sorry I'm if I'm being a
little bit if I'm sounding a little bit
rude but this is what it is I know this
for a fact because this is exactly the
mistake that I did right from my class 1
to my class 9 it was only in class 9
when my school teacher I mean bless him
I mean I mean God give him all the
blessings that is possible he introduced
me to these olymp type of problems and I
basically understood that I had not
learned maths at
all I simply had not learned maths in
all those 8 n years it was only when I
started doing those kinds of things that
I realized that that I had to
learn how to learn maths a fresh so
people who are committing the same kind
of mistakes that I did like learning
different kinds of methods uh and uh
just trying to map those meth methods to
the various categories of problems
please change your habits this is not
the way that you go about learning ma LS
maths so yes sure you have to learn
different methods you have to learn
different things but after after a
certain stage after a certain stage you
have to have to understand that you have
to come up with your own strategies you
have to come up like addressing problems
completely on your
own so when you do this okay and I'm
going to say something probably a little
bit unpleasant now so please listen
carefully if you do this and only if you
do this you will be able to
realize the strengths that you have many
people who join coaching from a very
early stage they go through this
regimented approach that the coaching
teachers give they they go about their
entire high school without realizing
properly what their real strength es
because they are just being given dose
after dose of different categories of
problems and different methodologies so
where is the
self-realization you don't even know how
if you are really good enough for the
kinds of things that you are aiming for
so by chance like the the the coaching
institutes now have nowadays have such a
sophisticated methodology of training
the students that by giving large doses
of this and through some kind of a
regimented approach they train the
students in such a fashion that they
push them through the barrier of the uh
of the of the entrance examinations
whether it is J or it is on neat and
then the students end up in the colleges
but when in the colleges there is no
such coaching or no such tution they are
completely flabbergasted at the level
they they realize that uh they have not
acquired any real problem solving and
then they fall flat on their face so uh
maybe this is not the right uh I mean uh
time to discuss all of these things but
this this is ultimately the consequence
of not learning problem solving in the
proper fashion what also happens is that
if uh if you are not at all I mean for
problem solving you do need a little bit
of a knack for genuine problem solving
and for certainly harder problems you
need to have some amount of uh innate
ability to do it
so uh if you do not have that innate
ability there must be a little bit of
that spark of imagination in you some
kind of independent thought thinking
capacity those kinds of things if they
are not there in you and if you're just
being pushed forward by the momentum
created by the artificial cosmetic
momentum created by your tution teachers
and coaching
teachers um you may think that just
because your parents are spending
thousands and thousands probably lacks
of rupees on your on your t on your
tution and coaching uh you probably uh
will end up in some good college but but
that is ultimately not not going to
happen Okay because in these
examinations you will always have to
face some kind of new problems for which
none of those uh categorized kind of
methodology will work this can happen or
even if you somehow manage to do it
you're never never going to get a good
rank so uh the best way to discover
yourself your innate abilities whether
you have them or not to develop those
abilities if you even if you have them
is high school okay so don't go for
tution fine go for coaching if you have
to if if your parents are forcing it
maybe that's another topic of discussion
uh but I would I personally think that
standard six or standard 7 to standard
10 is a very very precious time in which
you need to discover this kind of a
problem solving ability on your own uh
instead of wasting these years and I
using a strong word here instead of
wasting these years in going to coaching
and just being channelized your your
energy being channelized through this
regimented fashion okay the next thing
the next biggest mistake uh which many
people re do not realize is the
importance of acquiring language skills
in school this is certainly not going to
happen in uh in in any coaching
Institute perhaps it can happen in some
tution but the best place to to to
Really acquire this thing is at school
okay so uh if you are neglecting your
school education it is going to come at
the big price of not learning language
skills properly there could be debates
about the quality of the school
education that is available to you but
uh that is a slightly separate aspect
but I still believe that uh no matter
what kind of school you are going to
there are ample opportunities for you to
get some to extract some amount of
benefit on this regard again uh let me
discuss how you go about acquiring
language
skills so you go to school the teacher
starts a chapter and by the way when I
say language skills uh I of course in my
head I'm thinking English because I went
to an English medium school that is uh
that was what I was trained for but
whatever I say it applies equally well
to any other language also so acquiring
language
skills um and and by that I mean Reading
Writing comprehension effective uh
communication all these things if it
happens very nicely if it develops to a
certain level of maturity in one
particular language I think it is not a
big leap uh to go from one language to
another of course there are challeng
challenges but this this is kind of a
mental muscle that you develop if like
my PhD adviser used to say this there
are certain students who don't even know
how to to communicate effectively in
their own mother tongue that is really
unfortunate okay so forget about English
at least in in whatever language is what
whatever the language of medium of uh is
the medium of instruction in your school
develop this uh this language uh skills
in that language itself so how do you go
about doing this the typical way so your
teacher starts a
chapter uh explains the things and uh
there will be a set of typical questions
which are typically asked in the board
examinations and there are some
typically officially acceptable answers
which you are supposed to prepare you
prepare them and then you mug them up
and then and then vomit them in the
examination this is the classical the
typical way in which so-called language
skills are required in our schools uh in
some schools it is a little bit better
but uh ultimately it is a again a very
uh regimented kind of thing so I think
that is rather unfortunate now I'm
trying to emphasize this not because um
I want to emphasize uh a some kind of
putative uh holistic liberal kind of
education uh those are important things
but I mean this in terms of the actual
preparation which will be helpful to you
later on if you actually go on to
prepare for J and neat okay so I am
actually speaking in a very
business-like fashion here I mean
acquiring knowledge and developing
personality and all those things is fine
uh but here I'm actually talking on that
on that line so why is acquiring these
language skills
important it is important because when
you go to college uh well even before
College when you go to plus two and
especially if you are in the science
stream then you will see that you will
have to go a severe leap I mean leveling
up uh in terms of the kind the the the
the challenges that you'll have to face
in learning chemistry and
physics okay also in maths but certainly
in chemistry and physics you'll have to
you'll see uh just when you enter class
11 uh there is a tremendous leap up in
the level this jump this abrupt jump is
something which cannot be handled by
many many students I was uh like in the
top 20 of my state board in class 10
despite that okay so I faced severe
challenges in my class
11 okay and this is despite the fact
that I had actually I mean gone through
a very classical type of school
education which is what I'm espousing
here so if you're neglecting a big
aspect of your school education which is
language it is going to bite back at you
in class 11 and why is that because
you'll have to study many things on your
own and when you study many things on
your own from books unless you have the
proper ability to comprehend the things
and extract the meaning out of it you
are not going to be able to understand
anything deeply enough no matter how
much your teacher may explain to you
unless you sit with your book devotee
yourself to the to each and every line
try to read between the lines and try to
comprehend and extract the meaning you
are not going to be able to understand
it this is the this is the Stark truth
I'm telling you okay so maybe in school
you can get by without really
understanding or without understanding
Yourself by reading the books by the by
the momentum that is created uh again
I'm using those words by your tution
teacher and coaching but uh uh
ultimately you are going to face this
tremendous wall of difficulty uh when
you go into class 11 unless you have
acquired the language skills properly
and again nowadays coaching institutes
have developed this this tremendously
sophisticated regimen that uh I mean
they they they they give um students
Learning Materials in micro capsules and
students can take bite-size chunks out
of it and learn learn the various
Concepts in a very fragmented fashion
and they keep on doing this all through
their plus two somehow they manage to
get through the entrance examinations
But ultimately when it comes to the
undergraduate education they absolutely
fall flat I have seen this happen time
and again many students simply do not
have the skill to learn themselves to
learn things on their own on a from a
book forget books even if I give them
lecture notes fully typed out lecture
notes they find it extreme extremely
difficult to read through a passage to
to read through a through a piece of
text and extract meaning out of it this
is the sad truth okay so school is where
you develop this kind of a proper
language skill how do you go about doing
it well it is not going to merely happen
from your school
textbooks yes so uh what I mean by that
is
yes you'll have to learn from whatever
uh textbook of the Lang of the language
that is prescribed to you but you will
also have to develop a reading habit
whether it is from newspapers or some
kind of uh simple magazines maybe even
if it's a Sports magazine and mind new
sports magazines have beautiful language
many of the things which I have learned
in school and which I actually used in
my own essays and um story writings are
were actually acquired from sports
article articles uh this is a big secret
uh another thing is that you should
develop the habit of reading fiction
because there are many truths which are
embedded in fiction and it develops your
empathy and your ability to hold kind of
opposing thoughts in your brain these
are the kinds of skills and maturity
which uh needs to develop while you are
at school many students uh they say I
have I've seen this these kinds of
comments that oh in such and such
Advanced country such and such a thing
happens and in India there is no such
opportunity uh this and that yes we lack
opportunities but at the same time you
have to understand that in those kinds
of so-called Advanced countries the kind
of education which is expected from the
students even at the uh uh School level
involves a lot of reading on their own
so are you doing are you will you be
willing to do that so when you develop
this ability to read on your own to
extract meaning even from friction uh
then from stories from novels then you
develop an ability to uh to actually
encounter uh a completely alien piece of
text and uh develop a general ability to
extract meaning out of it which is going
to stand you in tremendously good Steed
once you enter college so this is the
the school level
from standard 7 to standard 10 is high
time where you absolutely need to
develop this ability furthermore not
just in reading but also in writing
because uh this Reading Writing uh
presenting your thoughts in a coherent
fashion this is something which can only
be achieved in practice it takes years
and years of effort so the earlier you
start this it is better and earlier
means definitely at the very beginning
of high school itself so uh when you do
this this reading this writing and this
uh this habits and these skills when you
develop it kind of creates a different
kind of evolution of your mindset your
brain and uh later on when you encounter
different things uh different new things
it will actually help you to develop
coherent thoughts on your own it will if
you write something down if you read
read something and then write something
down it helps you not just to present
your thoughts but also to interact with
your own thoughts so writing is as much
important as it is uh for communicating
your thoughts as it is for clarifying
your own thoughts so when you can write
something in a clear fashion you are
actually clarifying things not just for
others but first and foremost for
yourself and that is the trick and the
big secret behind making excellent notes
so when you read something you
comprehend it you present it in in a
notebook by yourself in your own
language you are interacting with your
own thoughts you are uh and if you do
this very honestly uh then uh the kind
of understanding the in-depth
understanding that you are going to have
that is uh that is going to be truly
tremendous that depth of understanding
is uh is something absolutely Priceless
now you may be thinking that if you are
going to do all of this on your own then
what good are your school teachers for
well the school teachers can help you
step by step in leveling up this kind of
uh acquiring the skills so when you read
a text when you go to a to a school
teacher's lecture they can unlock some
new meanings for you help you to read
between the lines so these are small
small things of which uh if you are
observant enough you will uh see it
happening on a day-to-day basis in your
school education and unless you actually
go to school uh you're never going to uh
realize this so instead of school if you
end up just going to to a coaching some
kind of a dummy school this is never
going to happen Okay so on this note
I'll U I'll end this discussion I'm uh
I'm sure there are lots and lots of
other things which needs to be discussed
on these aspects but for for the sake of
uh this video I'll end I'll end here and
uh maybe in a future video I can uh I
can point out a few things which uh
would be important for the sake of the
parents also so on this note thank you
very much and all the uh very best